تعود معنا الان اميره مصطفى عطاء المنان
الموظفه في مستشفى الخرطوم التعليمي اميره
ساعود اليك اسمحي لي ان تعطينا صوره مفصله
عما يجري داخل المستشفى الان
يا اختي
الان داخل المستشفى
الحركه داخل المستشفى صعبه صعبه جدا
بالنسبه للشظائع
الشظائع
من البتاجي من الاطلاق النار المتبادل
والمستشفى لموقعه ذاته موقعه وسط منطقه
الحرب
هل يمكن ان اين تقع هذه المستشفى بالضبط
طبعا
غرب غرب غرب القياده
الجهه الغربيه للقياده القياده العامه
يعني انتم في محيط مبنى قياده الجيش
ايوه في محيط في محيط المبنى وفي وفي مرمى
في مرمى على النار
طب اين تجلسون الان هل هناك هل هناك من
مكان الى حد ما امن في المستشفى تستطيعون
وضع المرضى فيه والطاقم الطبي المتواجد
هناك
لا يوجد مكان امن هو العنابر اما الان
موجودين في مجموعه من العنابر
ويوجد مصابين مصابين من
الشجاع
بتدخل على المستشفى
وايضا اميره المصابين داخل هذه المستشفى
بسبب القصف الذي يحيط بالمستشفى وليسوا
مصابين من خارج المستشفى واتوا اليها
نعم نعم من داخل المستشفى
لا يوجد يعني طريقه
لجلب المصابين من خارج المستشفى
موقعه في وسط وسط
وسط المرمى مرمى النيران
طب هل هناك حاليا هي متوقفه خالص هل هناك
من مولدات في المستشفى هل هناك من من
مولدات تستطيعون تشغيلها في المستشفى
مولدات كهرباء اقله لا توجد كهرباء لا
توجد
اي اي مقاومات
[موسيقى]
للحياه في في المستشفى
لذلك انا اعطيت لكم بالمناسبه
الان الان
الناس الصائمين ما فطروا الى الان
ما فطروا لكن
المرضى
شيء من الصباح
ونحن بنعجب في الجروبات
لم نجد اي استجابه للغناء الى الان
اشكرك يا اميره مصطفى عطا المنان الموظفه
في مستشفى الخرطومه التعليمي التي تناشد
بان تتم مساعده هذه المستشفى لانها تقع في
محيط قياده الجيش
والقصف حول هذه المستشفى سبب باصابات داخل
المستشفى شكرا لك لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات